hey there this is Con O'Brien welcome to
con bran why is everyone laughing you
gave it such a buildup like it was going
to be something revolutionary you did
weird voices with your mouth I warmed up
I went and then I went hey there this is
Con O'Brien welcome to con obb Brien
needs a friend ah the podcast that gives
and gives and gives and then eventually
gives out that's that's that's the key
sitting here with of course Matt gorley
Matt how are you hi I'm good thanks
usually IV introduce Sona first but I
thought I'd flip it up oh okay show you
that I'm agile I have an agile mind Sona
how are you shake things up are
introducing Mt first yeah yeah you never
know what's going to happen here keep it
fresh keep it fresh how are you I'm good
I'm not bad I'm cool okay all right very
good you want what do you want me to say
more no I think that's I think that's
adequate you know you did the minimum
amount that you should do I am fine and
you I think AI is do you think AI can
ever replace son everyone's talking
about what a can do there already are AI
podcasts of say Joe Rogan and I'm sure
there's already been some of you you
think so yeah I think this is very
easily aable I don't know my mind is so
hard to program or categorize I could
see algorithms being confused by my
magical brain really cuz the listeners
should know that Sona and I are just
sitting in a room with an AI machine
right I think the two of you are not
aable but I think I am I laugh and I
just go oh God
kind like that's what I do and that's F
you're right yeah we could probably just
take uh clips of Sona oh absolutely you
know oh boy huh oh really really that's
what you think yeah and then we just
split our salary uh well I would retain
it all I believe oh what's in it for me
then oh nothing you get nothing and I
get more
Falcons I really got into falconry over
the summer yeah oh you did wouldn't it
be great if that was something I got
into and I had the the glove and I had a
whole bunch of Falcons and they had the
little blinders on and I had the jackets
that they wear when they you should do
that no you'd be the least falcony guy
that's ever Falcon cuz you'd just be
like this the whole time like covering
your face yeah yeah yeah I'd wear a um
you know what people wear uh when
they're fencing I'd wear one of those
complete cages around my face and and
the Falcon would be rolling his eyes a
lot oh
God
they put they put the Blinder on they
put the Blinder on just so I couldn't
see it roll its
eyes that's what they're there for I
would have sarcastic Falcons sarcastic
passive aggressive
Falcons anyway I'm always been
fascinated by the idea of uh falconry
you should do it have you ever done it
no I I I think we did on late night we
did so many animal segments over the
years that I know I've probably had I'm
sure I've had a falcon on my shoulder
and a falcon on my arm fans can look for
it and that sure it'll come up instantly
whenever I say no I've never done blank
instantly someone can find it on the
internet C Brian needs a friend is
brought to you by T-Mobile from
listening to your favorite podcast while
driving cross country to listening at
home T-Mobile helps you stay connected I
wonder what people's favorite podcast is
oh I've got some ideas actually it's one
idea you'll figure it out T-Mobile is
America's largest and fastest 5G Network
you can have seamless video calling oh
that's good streaming your podcast not
going to say which one it is yeah
downloading apps games boy you know what
a gamer I am you're such a gamer play
Starbursts yeah or realm of
xanos you can watch your favorite TV
episodes classic Conan new Conan old
Conan mid-season Conan as long as it's
Conan oh no find out more at
t-mobile.com Network fastest based on
media and overall combined 5G speeds
according to analysis by ukla of speed
test intell data for q1 2023 c5g device
coverage and access details at
t-mobile.com
so yes I'm certain that I've done it on
television but no I don't even know how
I would actually to be honest with you I
don't even know what it is I think it's
a thing now actually in the LA area like
a sort of thing that hipsters can go do
and stuff is hipsters do everything that
comes from another time and has no use
right do you know what I mean like
churning butter axe throwing axe
throwing surgery
I want you know I want a hipster surgeon
when it's time for me to have surgery I
want a hipster to do it these are
authentic rust Laden tools from the 18th
century exactly yeah we we do surgery
before the way it was done before the
20th century because it all got so
sterile
yeah we do it with these Rusty tools and
uh we all grow weird beards and we don't
clean them and then the beard the oily
beard hair falls into your open wound
yeah you hipsters what we're doing
no we're not doing that oh I thought we
were doing that cuz you guys got a
little that's half of Matt's
friends you got to admit no I don't have
hipster friends you don't have hipster
friends come on no I don't think I do I
think I have pretty Square friends okay
yeah well some squares are also hipsters
I guess that's true maybe I don't know
you can't judge yourself from within huh
what what are you guys talking about you
know what you've tried to sell that
poster to college campuses you can't
judge yourself from within and it's a
cat hanging on a limb or it's Einstein
sticking out his tongue I bet I you
can't judge yourself from within you
know it be great to just come up with
terrible slogans and try and sell them
to college campuses you be so good at
that you're the one that you knew you
had to be yeah and then there's a
turtle bumping heads with another turtle
just try to sell those on campus watch
yourself get
married you just what's the image that
no the image never has anything to do
with the same no it does yeah yeah like
glass of water yeah yeah it's just that
glass of water and then the saying is
whenever you think you were that was
what it
was it's just a Volks yellow Volkswagen
it's a yellow
Volkswagen tomorrow is yesterday's
idea of what you ate
and then it's a baby elephant sleeping
wearing a
sombrero we're going to sell that to
somebody really have merch I'm smelling
merch I want more can you do another one
these are fun well uh okay come on make
me
laugh
clown this AI is working pretty well it
is working really well it gets
him uh Sunshine is the regret you used
to
know during day
light and then just put underneath it
thorough you can just put anybody's name
underneath it you know what I'd love to
do is just is sell a whole bunch that
are like shit's going down
Gandhi that's good you know that's what
I want to
do who farted
[Laughter]
Fay back that up Jane
Austin I want to s those right
now got we're on
it right isn't that the isn't that back
that back that up Jane
Austin that's what we absolutely have to
do we're gonna get sued by everyone's
estate oh come on they're not paying ATT
fair use their copyright is expired how
Jane Austin talked yeah if anyone knows
it's you two about copyright law there
we go we're
good I'm crying I'm actually crying a
little
bit that fact that up got me really
good Drop It Like It's Hot ho
[Laughter]
Melville I'd hit that married Todd
Lincoln oh my God
we're going to sell these we should and
I don't see any legal or moral reason
why we should I don't think there could
be cuz you can do anything with those
historical figures if you've liked what
I've just said um write to me car of
make that poster
dude at 2222 Scooby-Doo Avenue uhhuh
yeah and I'll get right back at you
postage included no City no State oh
come on man yeah state of cool
oh of Here and
Now Yep shabadoo dingdong habab
day I got to pull a plug on this what is
wrong with you I'm the one person my
wife is going to have me attached to a
machine and then pull the plug she's
going to have the plug inserted just so
she can pull it and I'll be perfectly
healthy